[Music]
now this is what dreams are made of Joe
Jonas covering Hilary Duff if you listen
to the song you can really get what you
want out of it yeah and this Joe Bro
knew what he wanted a fresh take on
Hillary's early odds hit come clean
wake me
[Music]
because hey veteran Disney stars gotta
support each other I'm Shane Gray for
crying out loud
Joe and his band dnce posted their
version of the 2003 Classic on Instagram
[Music]
[Music]
and Hillary loves the throwback tribute
sharing it to her own story with a cry
face and hearts emojis along with the
caption ah that is so sweet and get this
Joe actually teased the video the day
before seemingly with a reference to the
infamous Lizzie McGuire reboot which
wasn't meant to be hello I thought we
were talking about me here but Joe's
ready to right that wrong campaigning
for the show's comeback in his caption
well we don't think that's gonna happen
we're happy with any nod to Hillary's
pop star Glory Days
come clean is my second single from the
album and it's really it's a cool song
and it just kind of shows the
progression throughout the day of me
staying at home and having a thought in
my head but nobody really knows what I'm
thinking about is kind of a reflection
of the relationship that it's talking
about you know that it's a square
doesn't fit into a circle it's also hard
for me to have a relationship though
because I don't want to date anybody in
the business hey to break it to you 2003
Hillary but 2022 you is married to
musician Matthew coma who masterminded
this Jonas themed prank at your house
[Music]
somebody
's you
explained how did the Jonas Brothers to
all our family photos to see if the wife
notices
[Music]
well Hillary noticed writing nothing
surprises me anymore as for Joe whose
face was pasted over photos of their
children he said I love you Papa we're
obviously honored but Joe and his wife
Sophie Turner actually kicked off the
social media Antics last year when the
couple dressed as characters from the
Lizzie McGuire Movie
this is what dreams are made of and Joe
captioned this pic what else sing to me
Paulo
[Music]